Hello, everyone.
It is a tremendous pleasure to be here
to share with you my story.
You’ve all heard of brainwaves.
For a long time, neuroscientists
didn't know what they meant.
But we slowly come
to understand their purpose.
The brain generates waves
with different paces or frequencies
to transmit information and thoughts
by coordinating the activity
of nerve cells.
These waves are a little like the effect
of the orchestra conductor waving a baton
to keep the musicians synchronized.
I'm going to talk today
about the waves that have
the so-called gamma frequency.
These gamma waves
are particularly important
for synchronizing brain activity
to process new information
from the senses and for
learning and memory.
You might be surprised to learn
that when these gamma waves
are weaker than they should be,
this may contribute
to Alzheimer's disease.
Indeed, my laboratory
and others have shown
that in people with Alzheimer's
and in laboratory mice
that model the disease,
gamma waves at the frequency of 40 hertz
have reduced power and synchrony
than they should be.
So back in 2015,
we got an idea.
What if we artificially
boosted these waves?
Would that affect Alzheimer's disease?
We have to know the answer
because we are an aging society.
As we have made progress
in treating many other health problems,
we've begun living long enough
to develop others.
In the last 20 years,
the Alzheimer's Association estimates
deaths from heart disease
declined by about seven percent.
But the number of deaths
from Alzheimer's disease
increased 145 percent.
One in three seniors in the US
dies [from] Alzheimer’s disease
or another dementia, they say.
And more than 11 million people
provide unpaid care
for their loved ones with Alzheimer's.
So this means that probably
most of us in this room
have known and loved someone
with Alzheimer's.
I am no exception.
One day when I was four,
I went out with my grandmother.
And when I looked up to her to say,
"Let's go home,"
She said, "Home.
Where is home?"
So to see if we could treat
Alzheimer's disease
by changing brainwaves,
we tried out different approaches.
By working with my colleagues,
Emery Brown and Ed Boyden at MIT,
we figured out that we could entrain
or stimulate increased gamma waves
by simply showing mice lights
blinking at that frequency.
This really works.
Showing mice 40-hertz flickering light --
and we demonstrated later,
placing of 40-hertz buzzing sound --
creates a 40-hertz disco
that increases the power and synchrony
of these waves across the brain.
The effect reaches key parts of the brain,
such as the prefrontal cortex,
where we do planning and reasoning
and the hippocampus
where we create memories.
So the light and sound
stimulation approach
seems cool and flashy.
Literally.
But what amazes the most
is that it produced profound
and widespread benefits
in mice engineered to model this disease.
Mice exposed to gamma light
and sound stimulation
had major reductions in protein build-ups,
amyloid plaques and tau tangles
that are hallmarks
of Alzheimer's progression.
The stimulation preserved
more of the connections
or synapses that bind
nerve cells into circuits.
More cells survived,
so the brain decayed less.
The brain naturally has open spaces
known as ventricles.
And in the brain of mice left untreated,
these ventricles became very big.
But in the brain of mice
exposed to gamma-wave stimulation,
these ventricles are closer
to the size of healthy mice.
And consistent with all of these
physical differences,
Alzheimer's mice exposed
to light and sound stimulation
show better performance
on learning and memory tests
than untreated mice did.
We are still studying
why stimulating gamma waves works.
But we have made some key observations.
The brain has immune cells
known as microglia
that are supposed to maintain health
by removing waste.
These cells change their form and activity
following gamma wave stimulation.
We've also seen that the blood
vessels in the brain
respond to the stimulation.
These vessels widen their diameters
to increase blood flow, for instance.
This improved circulation
may play a key role
in flushing out waste as well.
So, mice are nice.
But people are the point.
So my group and others have begun testing
gamma light and sound
stimulation in humans.
We've developed a delivery device
that our volunteers
can use in their homes.
It’s a poster-sized light box
with a speaker underneath
to produce synchronized
40-hertz sensory stimulation.
A little tablet in the middle
allows them to play videos
when they are getting stimulated.
Recently, we have begun to see data
emerge from these pilot clinical studies.
Annabelle Singer, a former
member of our MIT team
and now a professor at Georgia Tech,
recently published encouraging results
showing that gamma light
and sound stimulation
entrains stronger gamma waves in people.
And their brains show increased
connectivity and synchrony.
My group has made some similar findings,
including signs of preservation
of brain volume
and cognitive improvement.
A private company we co-founded,
Cognito Therapeutics,
has also seen benefits in human testing,
including reduced brain atrophy
and improvement in mental functioning.
While we still have more work to do
to determine the full clinical efficacy,
we have provided a lot of evidence
that this approach appears safe.
Our participants use
their devices consistently
and tolerate gamma wave stimulation well.
Unlike a drug,
this stimulation
is completely non-invasive
and has minimal side effects,
which could make
this approach very accessible.
We are now working to launch a new study
of whether gamma-wave stimulation
can effectively delay
the incidence of Alzheimer's disease.
Given the prevalence of Alzheimer’s
disease in our aging population
and how safe this gamma light and sound
stimulation approach appears to be,
I sometimes dream of a gamma society
where we integrate gamma wave stimulation
into our daily environment
through our lighting
or even our video entertainment.
Maybe we will have a better world
and a brighter future
if we can keep our brainwaves,
and therefore our mind
and memory, well stimulated.
Thank you.
(Applause)
Chris Anderson: Thank you so very much.
I actually would have so many questions,
but the clock is not our friend.
I'm going to ask you one.
The cause of Alzheimer's,
like, the implication
of what you're saying,
is that it's possible
that an actual causal factor
is this falloff in the gamma brainwaves.
Is that how you see it
or what is the picture?
Li-Huei Tsai: You know, obviously,
the causes for Alzheimer's disease
are very complex.
There are a lot of genetic factors
and environmental factors.
But one thing is that this compromise
of the gamma waves
happens very early
in the course of the disease.
And you know, as I alluded to earlier,
it has tremendous effects
on many different cell types,
many different functions in the brain.
So it is very likely
that these impaired gamma waves
leads to the build up
of the protein aggregates and pathology.
But I would also like to mention
that this impairment
of these other cell types
and other processes in the brain
can also impact the strength
of the gamma waves.
So if you think about
the pathophysiology of the disease,
it's like a runaway train
that eventually crashes.
So I think that this
light and sound approach,
what it does is to give
a break of this process
and give the brain an opportunity to heal.
CA: So you are not necessarily arguing
that gamma-ray therapy
would be a complete
prevention of Alzheimer's,
but that it could,
in combination with other things
it could play an absolutely critical role.
LHT: It depends on when
do you start the treatment.
So if you start early --
so that’s why we are now testing
whether this approach can delay
the incidence of the disease.
CA: If you start early enough,
you really believe,
that alone could delay materially
the onset of Alzheimer's.
LHT: We'll see,
we're starting a clinical trial.
CA: Thank you so much,
thank you for your work.
(Applause)